je reçois maintenant georges wolinski
pour la parution chez albin michel de
monsieur paul à cuba le roman dessiné
des aventures politiques exotiques d'un
petit fonctionnaire à moustache façon
réac que la baie des cochons transforme
en pourceaux concubin d'une cubaine
bonsoir georges salah bonsoir je ne sais
pas si vous avez d'accord sur la
définition de mon oeuvre qui quand même
un roman d'une grande envolée un vrai
roman russe un vrai roman pensait
vraiment je montre à la caméra c'est ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que c'est un genre
nouveau c'est un rebond dessinée voit la
couverture on fait comme la télé on
montre et puis voilà l'intérieur ça
c'est très à gauche je sais pas pourquoi
je suis trompé sur cette page
ya pas d ya pas de ça à chaque page
quand même hein voilà voilà comment il
ya les alcopops correct voilà mesdames
messieurs il ya quelques pages
correction bon alors c'est est prépublié
cet été dans charlie hebdo
j'en avais un peu assez de faire ce que
je fais d'habitude des dialogues
donc j'ai commencé cette histoire et
comme je faisais déjà il ya longtemps
pour paulette je n'ai pas du tout écrit
le synopsis j'ai commencé à créer les
personnages une semaine et puis j'ai
attendu deux semaines gérant que j'ai
continué semaine par semaine sans jamais
savoir comment ça allait se terminer
comme un vrai feuilletoniste en fait
c'est à dire ces salles inventant
j'adore travailler comme ça parce que je
m'amuse henry arrivants et puis il ya un
moment où les personnages font un peu ce
qu'ils veulent j'ai plus qu'à les
regarder mais c'est vraiment alors c'est
l'histoire d'un petit fonctionnaire
étriqué qui bosse à la mairie de paris
alors évidemment il connaît mon avis
assez loire à l'office des hlm
voilà j'ai utilisé ma ma culture journal
de journalistes de l'actualité elle
connaît tout le monde y sait comment on
peut arranger il est l'homme à tout
faire et il est au point tout est
jetable homme discret sur dans lequel on
peut avoir confiance qui n'a pas de vie
amoureuse et sexuelle
il est puceau les puceaux et quand ils
arrivent à cuba dont il part à cuba ses
rapports avec les autres sont
bouleversés parce qu'ils découvrent les
femmes il écoute la musique y découvre
la magie et voilà la révélation quoi il
devient un frère un saint il pratique la
religion de la santé riz à la religion
afro cubaine et il devient complètement
un autre main ça dure une semaine sont
vrais et il est obligé en revenant de se
mettre des lunettes de soleil puisque
son regard a changé sa démarche a changé
et puis en plus il est devenu un [ __ ]
oui c'est à dire qu'il ya un énorme sexe
ce qui fait bien plaisir à nos amis
cubaine
non mais c'est vrai c'est lui savait
même pas ils savaient pas ce qu'ils
avaient entre les jambes en fait mais là
quand il découvre ça ils varient en
profite après un mois j'ai mis tous les
fantômes moi j'aurais rêvé d'avoir un
énorme c'est bien sûr et parce que tout
le monde dit que c'est pas important la
dengue
ça aurait changé ma vie enfin bon alors
cuba apparaît quand même un peu dans ce
bouquin fait moins rire la cuba apparaît
un peu dans ce bouquin comme un lupanar
c'est à dire est ce qu'aujourd'hui
finalement les les gens comme vous et
d'autres vont pas à cuba un peu comme
d'autres vont à bangkok mais manny est
ce que c'est pas devenu un peu un an pas
des gens comme moi en tout cas les gens
comme vous en fait j'ai vu un truc je
suis allé à cuba la première fois en 70
et j'y allais pour des raisons de parce
que ça me plaisait que cette révolution
plaisir que ce peuple me plaisait jeu il
n'y avait pas de cette prostitution qui
convoie actuellement qui apparente il
faut pas vous exagérez quand même quand
vous dites que ça apparaît comme un
lupanar
c'est la première impression mais
évidemment si vous allez à la havane ou
dans les grandes villes comme santiago
des coupes mais si vous allez dans les
petits villages comme ça antonio del
ozman cela vous avez à faire une
population dévoué et vivant modestement
avec des enfants qui sont à l'école
jusqu'à 4h30 en uniforme
il faut à côté de du cloaque et
l'amérique latine
mais j'ai tout un pays les gens sont
quand même et c'est autre chose
alors toute façon vous êtes assez
élogieux avec cuba malgré tout parce que
vous dites je vais lire la quatrième de
couverture
l'amitié le rhum la dignité les cigares
la beauté l'amour la musique la fois la
danse le courage le seul pays d'amérique
latine
alors attention le seul pays d'amérique
latine où les enfants sont moins
nombreux que les profs les médecins plus
nombreux que les malades les délinquants
moins nombreux que les flics et où il y
a plus d'analphabètes parmi les
touristes que parmi les habitants je ne
doute pas que ce soit vrai mais c'est un
peu la géographie quand même pour cuba
c'est un peu baba coûte si on ne peut
pas dire du bien des amis on ne parlait
pas des prisonniers politiques par
exemple
bon c'est pas le propos du livre point n
a pas tellement que ça votre ami delfeil
de ton sénat mia boudé le fait de temps
cette rue bien suivi enfin des apparats
par le free jazz est d'accord sur
beaucoup de choses
votre famille delfeil de ton disait dans
le nouvel observateur contre vous
derrière mais castro été réélu pour cinq
ans à l'unanimité par les députés élus à
l'unanimité et tous les candidats
étaient des candidats uniques sur des
listes uniques et dans la presse
occidentale la seule chose qu'on a
retenu de ça c'est que castro a parlé
7h30 s'en aller pisser on n'a jamais
parlé de ce dont parle d'elle feuille de
temps il ya cuba c'est comme une
dictature georges on peut pas en parler
aussi une indulgence
c'est bien de reconnaître parce que ces
tranches à l'arrêt du coup
absolument parce que il ya eu c'était
presque une réussite et il ya quelque
chose de beau qui sort de tout ça on
peut on peut penser ce qu'on veut de moi
je reste quand même un ami de ces gens
là mais vous de façon vous aime toutes
façons donc vous pouvez dire ce que vous
voulez vous aller à priori favorable
enfin chez moi et chez beaucoup de gens
mais est ce que ce n'est pas le même
sentiment sérieusement que vous risquer
d'encourir les mêmes critiques que
celles qui vous ont assailli quand vous
en 79 zettel et en urss souvenez de ce
voyage ça fait un scandale
vous allez en urss
vous étiez pas j'ai pas spécialement
gêné par les gens qui étaient au goulag
est ce qu'aujourd'hui finalement on peut
pas vous reprocher de ne pas pu savoir
d'intérêt pour les pour les prisonniers
politiques de cuba que pour les gens qui
étaient au goulag en 79
ça montre que j'ai pas changé je m'en
fous ouais mais le goulag à l'époque zi
est ce vraiment important qua non j'ai
pas dit ça ouais je voulais je vous dise
que vous avez dit à l'époque
moi je l'aimé de les juifs un jour on
vous disait les juifs ils les vire du
rso lire les juifs ils les vire en urss
ils ont bien raison puisqu'ils sont par
contre ils peuvent pas vraiment bien
j'avais raison oui bon enfin on peut pas
à la fois si vous voulez passer six mois
à juger papon et en même temps accepter
que les brèches nef vire les russes du
rss si on peut pas faire deux poids et
deux mesures
ce que je disais c'est que les gens
vivaient pas si mal que ça
là-bas que moi quand j'étais jeune je
vivais plus mal qu'un camp russe
oui oui la france dans les années 50
faut voir comment vous vivez sur
l'afghanistan par exemple vous dit je
suis la situation je la déplore mais je
la condamne pas quoi non c'est déjà
l'époque ça d'ailleurs j'ai eu raison
on a vu le bordel de ses demi avant il
valait mieux tout sur les russes qui
hélas bannissement oui vous dites que
l'ouzbékistan c'est mieux que
l'afghanistan vous disiez à l'époque et
qu'il aurait mieux fallu à tous bec cave
dont non mais vous avez le mérite de
tenir vos positions non mais par exemple
pour en revenir à cuba par exemple dans
les années 50 quand on est en vacances
en espagne on vous disait ne va pas en
vacances c'est franc kos un dictateur
après quand on est en vacances en grèce
on vous disait vas pas en vacances chez
les colonels pataky le fait d'aller en
vacances chez castro c'est un peu la
même chose finalement non ces
indicateurs tout ça si les gens ils vont
si les gens veulent aller se dorer le
cube valade héros faire un voyez des
voyages touristiques moi je vivais parce
qu'il ya des dessinateurs il ya une
ambiance qui me plaît je fais un travail
humanitaire là bas aussi lille me plaît
mais tous ne me plaît pas tout le plus
bas dans ce livre je me dis je dis tout
ce qu'il a eu il est passé bien entendu
tout n'est pas il faut bien dire c'est
pas du sang rapport sans nous et y est
fixé dans les frites et yann eyriac il
ya un dessinateur espagnol qui est une
chose formidable il a dit un ami c'est
quelqu'un dit qui dit du mal de toi
devant toi moi je dis ou qu'il va quand
j'y vais je dis mais qu'est ce que c'est
ça et pourquoi ça a changé ça alors ils
essayent de m'expliquer j'ai dit comme
inscrit pourquoi vous acceptez de cette
prostitution alors le ministre déjà en
phase où le dip
il me dit elle sont majeurs font ce
qu'elles veulent parce que
oui puis c'est la sexualité là bas c'est
pas pareil tout à fait que chez nous à
14 15 ans elles sont mères la plupart
sont r&d jason un enfant donc au canada
non à 18 ans et donc ça veut dire qu'ils
auraient des totalitarismes qui serait
plus acceptable que d'autres
il faut s'entendre sur le vote de
totalitarisme à cuba je le sens pas
comme ça moi ouais vous faites bien d'un
côté castro et l'autre côté le peuple et
le peuple il souffrait bien quand même
de cette situation non il souffre pas du
totalitarisme cuba s'est passé à quillan
maire de plus il souffre s'il n'a pas de
l'est il a pas de beurre et qui n'a pas
de prix qui a pas rien à manger c'est
surtout ça il souffre plus du blocus que
deux tu as trop bon donc vous ne pensez
pas la vie pas du tout vous avez dit une
fois je ne suis pas contre l'ambiguïté
j'envie donc on en est là toujours
toujours très bien merci
c'est à la prochaine voilà que jean
lapeyre ne suis pas déçu ah non moi je
vous prends que vous êtes comme vous et
cuba monsieur paul à cuba wolinski donc
un roman dessiné excellent je vous
conseille c'est chez albin michel merci
beaucoup georges et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous il m'était impossible